[Applause]
which king kong movies are classics and
which should have never left the island
he has every king kong movie ranked
worst to best
with a zero percent tomato meter score
king kong lives as the worst king kong
movie
and it's also in the running for worst
movie ever released 10 years after
dino de laurentiis's king kong in 1976
king kong lives as a sequel nobody
wanted to the remake nobody asked for
with none of the stars from the first
film and a fraction of the budget
turns out king kong survived his nearly
2 000 foot full
from atop the world trade center but he
needs an artificial heart to survive
if that isn't bizarre enough the film
also features kong
courting a female kong we can understand
that dilaurentis wanted to make a sequel
albeit 10 years after anyone cared but
was this really the best they could do
king kong lives came out 53 years after
the original king kong
and yet its special effects are less
convincing while king kong stop motion
animation was groundbreaking
king kong lives opted for the more
primitive filmmaking technique
of putting a man in a gorilla suit it's
little wonder king kong lives was a
raspberry award nominee for worse
special effects
king kong lives bombed with 4.7 million
dollars worldwide
effectively killing off the character
for 20 years
king kong lives came out 10 years after
1976's king kong
an eternity between sequels but
hollywood didn't always move so slowly
the original king kong was released in
new york city on march 2nd
1933 and its sequel son of kong came out
on december 22nd
1933. yep rko pictures wrote
produced edited and released a sequel in
nine months
but while you can respect their work
ethic you can't respect the finished
product
son of kong is just over 69 minutes long
so it barely even qualifies as a feature
film
and it's so thrown together that it
barely qualifies as a movie going
experience
as for the plot col denim the explorer
filmmaker from the original movie
has been sued into bankruptcy and
returns to skull island in the hopes of
finding treasure to pay off his debts
but instead he finds a 25 foot tall
albino
baby kong instead son of kong killed
whatever chance kong had of being a
multi-film series
it was only natural that king kong
remake would arrive in the 1970s
the same era as a towering inferno the
poseidon adventure and jaws
naturally the man to bring it to the
screen was dino de laurentiis
de laurentiis didn't know the meaning of
the word small and assembled a 24
million dollar budget
about 108 million dollars today to top
spielberg's killer fish
the production spent 1.7 million dollars
alone on a 40-foot tall kong animatronic
made with 3.5 tons of aluminium and 1012
pounds of argentinian horsetails
but it was barely even used in the film
the eight-month shoot featured 12 hour
days which tested the resolve of its
stars jeff bridges
and charles grodin as well as jessica
lang in her first major part
oh god i'm tired of thinking
and since this was the 1970s they
couldn't just make a movie they also had
to make a statement
grodin's evil oil exec travels to kong's
island seeking black gold but he
exploits the famous big gorilla instead
while king kong mostly relied on the man
in suit technique that looked less
realistic than its 1933 predecessor
the movie still snagged a special
achievement oscar for special effects
king kong earned 52 million dollars
making it the fourth biggest hit of 1976
but it was disappointing considering
that was just 20 percent of what jaws
earned the year before
today kong fans rightly viewed
dilaurentis's king kong
as a monster disappointment following
the enormous success of king kong vs
godzilla in 1962
rko allowed touhou studios to produce a
sequel
soho pitched a script pitting the mighty
ape against a giant lobster
ebira which rko rejected rko now
mandated that toho co-produced the film
with american studio rankin bass which
was featuring king kong in a popular
saturday morning cartoon
the king kong show in fact there was
already a script produced which was
basically a big screen remake of the
cartoon
the result was king kong escapes soho
pulled out all the stops for this film
assigning its top kaiju director ishii
rohanda to the project
alongside a-list actors akira takarada
and miyahama
however king kong escapes isn't a sequel
to the original kong or even king kong
vs godzilla
instead it exists in its own universe
this film has a lot of plot
but basically king kong rescues an
expedition from a dinosaur
is brought back to tokyo and must stop a
mad scientist from taking over the world
by battling his own mechanical double
mechanicong in other words you should
absolutely watch it
king kong vs godzilla screams no brainer
but its path to the big screen was
anything but straightforward the
stop-motion genius behind the original
king kong willis o'brien
wanted to pick kong against
frankenstein's monster
but universal nixed the project
o'brien's pitch made its way to touhou
studios
but they wanted to replace
frankenstein's monster with their own
creation
godzilla who'd been on a seven-year
hiatus a new script was written without
o'brien's knowledge
and king kong vs godzilla was born the
film is a landmark sci-fi film that
launched the kitschy colorful spirit
that would define the previously somber
godzilla series
the film was a massive fit in japan and
so it was rewritten to feature american
actors
and distributed in the united states
where it performed well
contrary to popular law there's no
alternate japanese ending where godzilla
swims off in victory instead of kong
however the original japanese version is
much different from the american one
and it's really more of a comedic satire
this version was elusive until criterion
collection released it
in 2019 whichever version you see king
kong vs godzilla
is a classic of the kaiju genre and one
of kong's most famous cinematic
appearances
gareth edwards godzilla brought the big
g back to american movie screens in 2014
defying even the highest expectations
when it opened to 93 million dollars
and earned 524 million dollars worldwide
on a 160 million dollar budget
kaiju flick suddenly meant cash and
legendary pitchers also hope to
capitalize on moviegoers sudden appetite
for cinematic crossovers
inspired by the success of the marvel
cinematic universe the company launched
its own series
the monster verse the next film in the
series would bring back
arguably the most famous monster in
movies king kong
kong skull island assembled a stacked
cast but the biggest star was kong
skull island wasn't a sequel or remake
but a reboot and it balloons the monster
ape's height to 100 feet
and dialed the cinematic spectacle up to
11. it somehow managed to pay homage to
apocalypse now
and still give audiences what they paid
to see big monsters fighting each other
kong skull island received a 75 tomato
meter ranking
and earned 168 million dollars
domestically
and 566 million dollars worldwide on a
185 million dollar budget
making it the most successful movie so
far in the monster verse
kong skull island is better than it had
any right to be with strong performances
a breakneck pace
compelling characters you love to root
for and enough cinematic monster carnage
to create the perfect saturday matinee
nearly 60 years after king kong vs
godzilla the big lizard got his rematch
in 2021's godzilla vs kong
besides being a much better movie than
the original godzilla vs kong could be
more historically significant too
that's pretty impressive considering
king kong vs godzilla was groundbreaking
launching the touhou godzilla series
from a black and white sombra affair
into the brightly coloured light-hearted
godzilla vs fill in the blank format we
know and love
however godzilla vs kong received the
widest sea at account of the pandemic
era while also being released on
streamer hbo max
which for many analysts signaled the
beginning of a return to normalcy
you couldn't find a more unlikely
candidate godzilla king of the monsters
underwhelmed dronium from the summer of
2019
casting the monster versus future in
doubt godzilla vs kong seemed destined
to disappoint
then the first trailer dropped and
became the fourth most liked trailer
ever
in some strange way godzilla vs kong
became the movie audiences needed
as critic shirley lee wrote in the
atlantic it's kind of admirable how
aggressively godzilla vs kong excuse any
grander meaning
in an era where every big dumb
blockbuster thinks adding darkness and
meaning makes it better
godzilla vs kong succeeds because it's
just a big dumb blockbuster
seriously if you're looking for epic
fights between towering beasts
or if you just really want to see an
oversized gorilla wielding an axe well
adam wingard's action flick is
definitely the film for you
whatever godzilla vs kong ultimately
means for movie history
it already has become one of the best
king kong movies of all time
2005's king kong isn't really a remake
so much as it's the biggest example of
fan fiction in cinematic history
as roger ebert put it in his four star
review king kong was quote
like the flowering of all the
possibilities in the original classic
film
director peter jackson loved king kong
ever since he was a kid
and with his newfound creative freedom
coming off the lord of the rings trilogy
he sought to bring the ape back in the
biggest way imaginable
but as with every other king kong movie
the path was anything but easy
a pre lotr peter jackson pitched a king
kong remake to universal execs in the
mid-1990s
while the studio wasn't bored with his
vision execs both when they realized a
new godzilla and mighty joe young were
coming out first
and they feared what might happen if
their movie showed up late to the party
a heartbroken jackson took refuge in
j.r.r tolkien's masterwork
raising his stock considerably jackson
eventually got a titanic sized 207
million dollar budget
and an epic three-hour run time it was a
lot but after the success of the lord of
the rings trilogy
universal figured it was a bargain well
king kong received an 84
tomato meter score it's 218 million
domestic and 562 million dollars
worldwide box office gross
underwhelmed based on its budget is it
too long
maybe but while kong's epic length
proved too much for many moviegoers
kong diehards believed peter jackson's
love letter to the original
couldn't last long enough after all the
relationship between the big ape and
naomi watts's andero
feels genuinely sweet and the fantastic
sequence where kong battles a bunch of
dinosaurs
is a kind of scene that movies were made
for
king kong is one of the greatest movies
ever period
big budget genre blockbusters dominate
movies today
and king kong was first only star wars
comes close to its influence on special
effects
and at nearly 100 years old king kong is
still the best stop-motion movie ever
the film is a 100 minute highlight reel
of iconic movie moments
from the beauty feyre screaming in
terror at the beast
to the mighty apes smashing through
skull islands and penetrable doors to
the heartbroken king kong taking his
last stand atop the empire state
building
king kong is truly a triumph of the
imagination the kind of cinematic
spectacle that could only be made in the
golden age of hollywood
oh no it wasn't the airplanes
it was beauty kill the beast but the
backstory of king kong is almost as
amazing as the film itself
globetrotting adventurer marion c cooper
developed projects for rko pictures
chief david o
selznick and he came up with the idea of
a giant gorilla picture
he was originally going to have a real
life gorilla fight a komodo dragon
but when that idea became untenable he
stumbled onto a dinosaur project called
creation
from the stop-motion mastermind behind
1925's the last world
willis o'brien inspired cooper thought
what if the gorilla fought dinosaurs
and a masterpiece was born king kong
cost five hundred thousand dollars
equivalent to ten million dollars today
which was a fortune at the time
but it was worth it king kong was a huge
hit and the eighth wonder of the world
still inspires all today
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite monster movies are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you